firefighters made good progress on the
sandy valley fire over the weekend the
fire is now
90 percent contained it's burning below
a mountain spring summit on the
backside of the spring mountains on the
prompt side of the spring mountains
the bureau of land management says it's
burned nearly 1400 acres
about 130 firefighters were on the
ground fighting that fire
to get a handle on it it's believed to
have been caused by
target shooting a round that reportedly
caused a spark and ignited dry
vegetation
so if you plan to go out target shooting
here's some things to remember
pick a safe spot don't shoot into rocks
or vegetation
and the type of ammo you use really
matters steel
core and solid copper solid copper ammo
are most likely to start fires and are
restricted this time of year
there are fire restrictions in the
mountains always bring a
shovel some water a fire extinguisher
good ideas just in case and lastly
do not shoot on hot dry windy days when
fire risk is high that's like today
there are red flag warnings for the
mountains today